i'm here shooting these last couple of
weeks here at largo
fargo and uh we we wanted to take over a
space
and uh there goes andy richter sneaking
by
hey
[Laughter]
going back to the dressing rooms there
yeah going back to the dressing rooms
that's right thanks sandy
who is that that's andy sandberg he has
no idea how
you didn't sell palm springs last night
it was really awesome thanks man
i really liked it whoa that's pretty
close he has no idea who's on the show
he comes in he doesn't know i'm shooting
an interview
he's going to go to that little bathroom
at the end of the hall little bathroom
at the end of the hall
you know what kind of operation we're
running here
[Laughter]
like any minute now chickens are just
going to come running across did you
guys
did you guys discuss maybe doing it on
the stage looking out
you like the back stage better because
of all that no no the stage is right
the audience is right here yeah i never
i don't think i ever got up there i
always wanted to i did stand up you know
back in the day
but yeah well maybe you will maybe uh
you'll come back here once this place
reopens
or you could just appear here in a
motion capture suit from your own home
as you're into a diaper political diaper
yeah
[Laughter]
you bleep the bleep the curses or do you
let the curses roll
man it's pandemic we let it all
hang out that's cool how many curses
how many curses would i have to say to
start getting bleeped i don't know i
actually have no idea i have no idea but
who could stop us anymore
it's [ __ ] true in the ass [ __ ]
diaper
taking a big old dumpy [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] mocap
oh man this is punk rock this is the cpg
of comedy look at that look at my hair
mopping oh
yeah yeah
he's been in that bathroom for a long
time yeah
richter to be he says he's out okay here
we go
okay um well anyway uh let me get the
word out on palm springs
okay thank you thank you palm springs is
available to stream on hulu
and uh i promise you it is a it is one
of the better movies you're going to see
uh for quite a while so see that
film and really terrific performances
and heartwarming and i'm very happy for
you
because you're also you're just terrific
in this movie
and uh i mean i just know that this is
this is a big deal this is a great movie
so
thank you out of you congratulations
seriously very happy thank you
thanks buddy and i look forward to
seeing you uh
in person so we can do this with our
hands and fingers we should see each
other in person
i i'm not good with hand signals
that was not subtle each other
[Laughter]
is that the right one i've never
understood hand signals going
andy sandberg thank you very much thank
you buddy